there are growing concerns that
america's push to manufacture and use
electric vehicles
could have a disturbing unintended
consequence a major percentage of the
batteries used in those vehicles
comes from china state department
correspondent rich hadson has our report
tonight
spending on record it's going to
boost america's innovative edge in
markets where global leadership is up
for grabs
markets like battery technology
biotechnology
computer chips clean energy the
competition with china in particular
in that competition china is well ahead
a report from research firm bloomberg
nef on lithium-ion battery supply chains
says china controls 80 percent of the
world's raw material refining
more than three quarters of global cell
capacity and 60 percent
of the planet's component manufacturing
that means realizing president biden's
transportation future of electric cars
would depend on china unless the u.s
develops its own capacity
part of his 2 trillion dollar
infrastructure plan features 174 billion
dollars for the electric car
network including battery supply chains
and charging stations
it will be important to watch where that
money is spent and how it's spent
will it be driven by political
considerations or will it be driven by
where the best research into batteries
is going
but there's opposition especially from
union workers
many whose current jobs would disappear
in a battery dominated transportation
system
michigan congresswoman debbie dingle is
in the middle of that fight
she tells fox news quote i have spent
too long with labor being pitted against
environmentalists
my last session of congress was sheer
hell i'm talking to the labor unions
every day and i'm talking to the
environmentalists
there are very honest conversations
going on between the two sides
another challenge timing as building
infrastructure in the u.s can often be
more expensive
and take longer than in other developed
countries
there is bipartisan support for
bolstering american manufacturing
especially after the global pandemic
highlighted how much of the medical
supply chain is based overseas
the question for congress is how to
bring that back
brett rich also from the state
department tonight the administration
taking another step toward getting the
u.s back into the iran
nuclear agreement that's right the state
department announced today brett that
the u.s would begin
indirect discussions with iran next week
in vienna
the countries still in the iran nuclear
deal would act as intermediaries
as part of all of this and try to
resurrect that 2015 agreement
also known as the jcpoa in a statement
state department says that
they'll discuss quote the nuclear steps
that iran would need to take
in order to return to compliance with
the terms of the jcpoa
and that the sanctions relief steps that
the united states would need to take
in order to return to compliance as well
diplomats close to the discussion say
the two sides
have already exchanged discussions and
ideas back to you
a little skeptical skepticism about how
that will all come out but we will
follow it
rich thank you